.
Ich war im Zug.
Ich sass ganz allein.
Die Familie sass
auf der anderen Seite.
Das Kind war unruhig.
Irgendwann sagte die Grossmutter:
"Jetzt bist du still,
sonst hole ich den schwarzen Mann."
Wir fallen auch einfach auf.
Es macht sehr müde. Sehr müde.
Es ist sehr, sehr schwierig in
der Schweiz über Rassismus zu reden.
Er wird verneint, aber trotzdem
ist er täglich präsent.
Immer dagegen zu kämpfen,
immer zu zeigen:
Ich bin doch einfach
ein Mensch wie ihr.
Der Polizist war allein, ich auch.
Ich merkte, sonst was niemand da.
Das ist ein beängstigendes Gefühl,
zu merken,
dass man einfach keine Chance hat,
dass man wirklich allein dasteht.
(Speakerin) No Justice!
- (Menge) No Peace!
Meine beiden Brüder -
v.a. der eine litt sehr darunter,
dass er tagtäglich
kontrolliert wurde.
Grundlos, nur weil er
eine andere Hautfarbe hat.
Z.T. versuche ich,
mich nicht an den Orten aufzuhalten,
wo ich Rassismus begegnen könnte.
Ich schütze mich persönlich
vor Rassismus v.a. mit Verdrängen.
Mit Rechtfertigungen,
mit dem Denken:
"Vielleicht hat die Person
einen schlechten Tag."
Wenn das Selbstwertgefühl
zerstört ist,
zerstört das den ganzen Menschen.
Wann haben wir denn genug gemacht,
damit man sieht,
dass wir hierher gehören wollen?
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Pulsierende Musik *
Was wird bei Ihnen operiert?
Hier.
- Okay, gut.
Wir bereiten Sie vor für die
Narkose, dann schlafen Sie nachher.
Dann fahren wir in den OP-Saal
und Sie werden operiert.
Daniel Kora arbeitet seit 17 Jahren
am Kantonsspital St. Gallen.
Kommentare zu seiner Hautfarbe
hört der Anästhesie-Pflegefachmann
jeden Tag.
Der Kollege hat sich angewöhnt, wenn
er einen Patienten zu mir bringt,
immer zu sagen:
"Sie müssen keine Angst haben."
Manchmal sagt er auch:
"Er ist auch ein Mensch wie wir."
Irgendwann hat es angefangen, mich
zu stören, auch wegen der Patienten.
Denn wenn man so etwas sagt,
dann denkt der Patient:
"Oh, ist der kompetent genug,
um mich hier zu betreuen?"
Eine Narkose
ist schon etwas Spezielles.
Die Patienten kommen, sie haben
Angst und dann diese Aussage.
Wir werden immer wieder
Ihren Namen rufen, okay?
Ich habe ihm das gesagt. Dann
hörte er für zwei, drei Tage auf.
Aber irgendwann
fing er wieder an mit dem Zeug.
Liegen Sie bequem so?
- (Patient) Ja, ja.
Wenn Sie schlafen, schauen wir
genau gleich gut zu Ihnen.
Ja, ja.
- Gut. Super.
Die Ausbildung zum Krankenpfleger
absolvierte Daniel Kora
Anfang der 1990er-Jahre
in seinem Heimatland Benin.
Dort lernte er
seine Schweizer Frau kennen,
die im selben Spital arbeitete.
In der Schweiz bildete er sich weiter
zum diplomierten Pflegefachmann
Anästhesie.
Diese Zeit war überschattet
von einem traumatischen Erlebnis:
Eine medikamentensüchtige Kollegin
entwendete unter seinem Namen Opiate.
Überall wo ich war,
hat das Medikament gefehlt,
ohne dass man es gebraucht hat.
Irgendwann hatte ich das Gefühl,
irgendjemand
will mich schlechtmachen.
Aber ich konnte nichts beweisen.
Irgendwann hatte ich das Gefühl, ich
müsse mit der Ausbildung aufhören,
weil mich das
so dermassen fertiggemacht hat.
Ich ging z.T. nach Hause
und heulte nur noch.
Aber gebe nicht schnell auf.
Ich habe weitergemacht
mit der Ausbildung.
Noch mal gut atmen,
solange Sie können.
Irgendwann kam es raus.
Die Kollegin,
die medikamentensüchtig ist,
hat sich selber verraten.
Dazu kommt:
Sie war meine Betreuerin.
Und dann sagte sie zu mir:
"Weisst du, Daniel, ihr Afrikaner
seid sowieso alle Drogendealer."
"Also kommt es
nicht mehr darauf an."
Das hat mich völlig fertig gemacht.
Wir fangen an mit dem Körper.
Wir machen einen Halbkreis.
Wir beginnen mit dem Körper
und versuchen, uns zu strecken.
Warum
reproduzieren wir ständig Bilder?
Bei Rollenanfragen
bin ich ständig der Putzmann Ð
ohne das negativ zu werten Ð
oder irgendwie der Kriminelle.
Okay, versuchen wir's.
* Er macht ein brummendes Geräusch. "
* Sprechübungen *
Ich hätte in einer Serie
einen Arzt spielen sollen.
Ich bekam schlussendlich eine
Absage. Es hiess, das gehe nicht.
Ich dachte, weil ich zu jung sei.
Schlussendlich war die Antwort,
"Es sei zu unlogisch, ich als Arzt."
Okay, wir versuchen es einfach mal.
All die Rollenbilder,
die ich bekomme,
weisen ganz klar
auf eine "Schicht" hin.
Auch die Namen,
die ich dazu bekomme.
Es sind immer Mustafa oder Ali
oder so.
Ich verstehe es aus der Sicht, dass
man sagt, es passe, es sei logisch.
Aber wir sind
nicht einfach so einseitig.
Es gibt viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Kay Kysela gehört heute zum Ensemble
des Zürcher Schauspielhauses.
Er ging seinen eigenen Weg bis dahin:
Real-, dann Sekundarschule.
Ausbildung zum Krankenpfleger.
Anschliessend Schauspielschule
in Bern und Zürich.
Kay Kysela wuchs mit seiner Mutter
und zwei Schwestern
in Aarberg im Kanton Bern auf.
Wie gross? Soll ich
die klein machen, zum Einkochen?
Ja, ich koche sie ein.
In etwa so - kleine Stücke.
Jasmin Pfister
ist in der Schweiz geboren.
Seit sie denken kann,
ist sie mit Rassismus konfrontiert.
Wir gingen mal in eine Badi.
Und dann ...
... haben uns die Leute dort
so angeschaut.
Kinnlade runter.
Total, ja.
- Mund offen und so.
Ja, die haben geschaut und geschaut,
als hätten sie
noch nie Dunkelhäutige gesehen.
Das ist mir geblieben,
sehr geblieben.
Als wir so klein waren,
war es schon noch etwas anders Ð
eine alleinerziehende Mutter
und dann drei so dunkle Kinder.
Ich habe gelernt, damit zu leben.
Es ist einfach so.
Die Leute schauen einen
manchmal einfach an - lange.
Oder machen eine Bemerkung.
Es gab einfach immer wieder Momente,
an die ich mich erinnere.
Z.B. wenn es Streit gab,
haben sie das N-Wort gesagt.
Oder, weisst du, im Quartier vorne,
war es mal so,
dass sie Affengeräusche
gemacht haben
und Steine an unsere Türe
geworfen haben.- Ja.
Das ist schon ...
Das ist schon etwas,
was mir enorm geblieben ist.
Jasmin Pfister
arbeitet in der Pflege.
Eben erlebte sie
eine demütigende Situation.
Jemand, den ich hätte pflegen
sollen, wollte das überhaupt nicht
aufgrund meiner Hautfarbe
und meiner Afrohaaren.
Das ist ein bisschen das ...
Genau, einfach der Zugang ...
... und auch der Ton -
ich konnte kaum etwas fragen,
noch so gut gemeint.
Es war einfach
eine sehr ablehnende Haltung.
Eine rassistische Haltung -
mir gegenüber.
Er hat einfach
eine enorme Ablehnung gezeigt.
Gezeigt und ausgedrückt.
Ja, sie ist mein Mami.
Für mich ist das ...
Wenn jemand differenziert
aufgrund von Haaren oder ...
Das ist supertraurig.
Und gleichzeitig -
trauriger ist fast,
dass es mich
gar nicht richtig überrascht.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Meine Schwestern und ich
wurden so erzogen,
dass wir uns immer bewusst waren,
dass wenn wir etwas machen,
wenn wir im Dorf irgendwas anstellen
mit unseren Kolleg/-innen.
dann wird man sich an uns erinnern.
Ich glaube, das begleitet mich
durch mein ganzes Leben:
dass ich sehr darauf bedacht bin,
positiv aufzufallen,
freundlich zu sein -
um ja nicht negativ aufzufallen.
Salomé Kora: Eine der schnellsten
Sprinterinnen der Schweiz.
* Dynamischer, pulsierender Beat *
Es ist selten, dass mir jemand
etwas ganz Schlimmes
ins Gesicht sagt oder so.
Es sind eher subtile Kommentare.
Oder Anmerkungen
oder eher misstrauische Blicke.
Z.B. von einer Kellnerin
oder einem Kellner:
Wenn ich eine Frage stelle
oder etwas wissen will,
geht die Antwort direkt
an meine weissen Kolleg/-innen.
Das sind schon Sachen,
die mich verletzen
und die ich manchmal
zu überkompensieren versuche.
Ich will dann noch mehr zeigen,
dass ich gewisse Sachen weiss.
Ich gebe vielleicht
eine noch ausführlichere Antwort,
um der Person zu zeigen, dass sie
sich total in mir getäuscht hat.
Salomé Kora ist seit 2016
Teil der 400-m-Staffel.
Am Anfang meiner Geschichte mit
der Staffel gingen wir an eine WM.
Ich habe meine Tante gesehen - meine
weisse Tante mütterlicherseits.
Ich habe ihr das erzählt
und dann sagt sie:
"Wobei, Schweizer Nationalstaffel
kann man das ja nicht nennen Ð
es der Grossteil
ist ja eh dunkelhäutig."
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
* Gemütliche Reggaemusik:
"Get Up Stand Up" *
# Get up, stand up.
Don't give up the fight.
Das ist Roger Wilhelm.
Er ist der verstorbene Bruder
von Evelyn Wilhelm.
Seine Freunde nannten ihn Nzoy.
Im Sommer 2021
wurde er in Morges auf dem Bahnhof
von einem Polizisten erschossen.
Ein Jahr später versammeln sich
Hunderte Menschen in Zürich,
um an ihn zu erinnern und
gegen Polizeigewalt zu protestieren.
(Sprechgesang) No Justice, no Peace!
Alle zusammen gegen Rassismus!
Es ist ein gutes Gefühl,
ein tragendes Gefühl,
dass so viele Leute die
Ungerechtigkeit nicht mit ansehen.
Evelyn Wilhelm und ihr Bruder
standen sich sehr nahe.
Die Geschwister
wuchsen zusammen in Zürich auf.
In den Monaten vor seinem Tod
fand Roger Wilhelm
bei seiner Schwester Unterschlupf.
Es ging dem 37-Jährigen
psychisch nicht gut.
Bahnhof Morges. Feierabend.
Roger Wilhelm
hält sich auf den Gleisen auf.
Die Züge stehen still.
Passagiere filmen.
Ein Bahnmitarbeiter ruft
die Regionalpolizei in Morges an:
Es ist eine Person auf den Gleisen.
Während des Anrufs hört man Roger
Wilhelm immer wieder sagen:
Geht weg! Geht weg!
Knapp 3 Min. später:
Die Beamten sind vor Ort.
Ein Polizist funkt, dass Roger
Wilhelm ein Messer bei sich habe.
Sein Kollege zieht seine Waffe.
* Melancholische Klänge *
* Zwei Schüsse *
(Filmende Person) Oh! Oh!
Roger Wilhelm steht wieder auf.
Der Polizist schiesst noch einmal.
* Schuss *
Roger Wilhelm geht zu Boden,
bleibt verletzt liegen.
Kurz darauf im Polizeifunk:
Coup de feu! Schussabgabe!
Wir brauchen eine Ambulanz.
Die Beamten fesseln Roger Wilhelm
mit Handschellen,
durchsuchen ihn mit den Füssen.
Die Polizisten sichern ein Messer.
Roger Wilhelm bleibt liegen. Er
stirbt vor Ort an inneren Blutungen.
Nzoy erhielt keine erste Hilfe.
Die Vorstellung, dass die Polizisten
mehr als 4 Min. um ihn herumstanden,
ohne zu helfen, ist schrecklich.
Die Polizei behauptete,
sie habe erste Hilfe geleistet.
Videoaufnahmen zeigen,
dass das eine Lüge war.
That was a lie!
In der Medienmitteilung hiess es:
Doch das stimmt so nicht.
Später korrigierte die Polizei
ihre Mitteilung.
Gerechtigkeit für Nzoy!
No justice, no peace!
No justice!- (Alle) No peace!
No justice!- No peace!
* Applaus *
Evelyn Wilhelm ist noch immer
fassungslos über die Art und Weise,
wie ihr Bruder
ums Leben gekommen ist.
Ich verstehe bis jetzt nicht,
wie vier ausgebildete Polizisten
nicht mit einem Mann
sozusagen fertig werden,
ohne ihn töten zu müssen.
Sie haben keine Schlagstöcke,
keinen Pfefferspray, nichts benutzt.
Sie hätten andere Mittel gehabt.
In den Tagen vor seinem Tod
versuchte Roger Wilhelms Familie
ihn davon zu überzeugen, professio-
nelle Hilfe in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Er hat
einen sehr engen Freund verloren.
Das hat ihn ziemlich mitgenommen.
Er hat sich verfolgt gefühlt.
Er hat gedacht,
Leute wollen seinen Tod.
Gegen den Polizisten,
der die tödlichen Schüsse abfeuerte,
läuft eine Untersuchung.
Es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung.
Evelyn Wilhelm und ihre Familie kämp-
fen mit Hilfe eines Anwalts dafür,
dass die Umstände seines Todes
restlos aufgeklärt werden.
Ein Weg voller Widerstände.
Rassismus bekämpfen: Das
treibt Yvonne Apiyo Brändle-Amolo an.
Vor über 20 Jahren kam die
gebürtige Kenianerin in die Schweiz.
Merci! Bis später!
- (Frau) Bis später.
Seit 2015
engagiert sie sich in der SP.
Sie ist Gemeinderätin
im zürcherischen Schlieren
und im Vorstand der SP Migrantinnen
und Migranten Schweiz.
Wo ist denn Felix?
Bonjour! Chères et chers camarades!
Wenn ihr das Wort ergreift,
bitte macht euch bemerkbar!
Yvonne Apiyo Brändle-Amolo,
SP Migranten Schweiz.
In dieser Resolution geht es
um die ukrainischen Geflüchteten.
Sie erhalten sofort
den Schutzstatus S,
während die meisten Geflüchteten
aus Kriegsländern wie Afghanistan,
Syrien oder Kamerun hier oft jahre-
lang mit einer vorläufigen Aufnahme,
dem Ausweis F leben.
Das muss sich ändern.
So kommen wir
vielleicht zur Abstimmung.
Ein Saal mit rund 50 Leuten Ð
Yvonne Apiyo Brändle-Amolo
ist die einzige schwarze Person.
Wir haben in der ganzen Schweizer
Politik ein Repräsentationsproblem,
u.a. von Menschen mit dunkler
Hautfarbe - nicht nur, aber auch.
Viele Leute vergessen,
dass sie uns nicht nur
die Sichtbarkeit geben müssen.
Nicht einfach sagen:
"Jetzt haben wir eine Schwarze."
"Wir geben ihr eine Stimme. Sie darf
zwei Sätze sagen und das war's."
Nein,
wir wollen auch dazugehören.
Wir wollen, dass unsere Perspektiven
für Lösungen miteinbezogen werden.
Viele Leute nehmen die Anliegen,
die sie vertritt -
auch die Frage von Rassismus
und Diskriminierung,
aber auch Anliegen
von People of Color, von Frauen -
gar nicht richtig wahr,
auch innerhalb der Partei.
Darum ist es wichtig,
dass sie präsent ist.
Sie wirkt natürlich
auch gegen aussen.
Wenn Sie die ganze Hierarchie
anschauen, die ökonomische Kette,
sind die schwarzen Leute
immer am Ende.
Und wir haben sehr wenig Leute,
die den Mut haben,
die Plattform haben,
sich überhaupt zu äussern.
Sie können sich das nicht leisten,
diese Art von Kampf einzugehen.
Aber ich habe diese Möglichkeit,
denn jetzt, auch als Studierende
mit Nebenjob,
kann ich mir das leisten.
Sind wir hier?
Hallo.
Danke.
Voilà.
Woher kommst du her? Ursprünglich?
- Senegal. Und Sie?
Du kannst Daniel sagen.
Wie?
- Ich bin Daniel.
Ich komme aus Benin.- Benin?
- Benin, ja.
Benin! Nicht Berlin!
Das höre ich immer wieder.
"Wo kommst du her?" - "Benin."
- "Aah, Berlin!"
Unsere Töchter sagen:
"Das darfst du nicht fragen."
Untereinander schon, finde ich.
- Genau, oder?
Senegal und Schweiz. Sie stammt aus
Brasilien, in Deutschland geboren.
Und du?
- Schweiz, nur Schweiz.
Aber unsere Kinder
reden manchmal auch so wie ihr.
Ich arbeite in der Spitex.
Auf dem Land hat es ältere Leute,
die ...
... nicht so offen sind
gegenüber ausländischen Menschen,
die nicht verstehen können,
dass eine Frau keinen
richtigen Schweizer Bauern heiratet.
Sie wollen immer fragen,
woher mein Name kommt - Kora.
Manchmal sage ich es nicht,
weil ich das Gefühl habe,
es sei nicht so gut, es beeinflusst
ihre Haltung mir gegenüber.
Erzählen Sie Ihrer Frau
von rassistischen Erlebnissen?
Naja, nicht immer.
Warum nicht?
Am Anfang
wollte ich sie damit nicht belasten.
Oft ist es so ...
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass sie
so sehr leiden würde wie ich,
wenn ich ihr alles erzähle.
Und das wollte ich nicht.
Können Sie ein Beispiel nennen,
von dem Sie ihr nicht erzählt haben?
Am Anfang haben Arbeitskolleginnen
untereinander geredet.
Ich war dabei.
Dann fragten sie mich:
"Du, wie haben denn
deine Schwiegereltern reagiert,
als sie dich gesehen haben?"
Und dann habe ich gesagt,
sie seien sehr offen gewesen.
Ich hätte ein sehr gutes Verhältnis
zu meinem Schwiegervater.
Er war ein offener Mensch.
Und dann sagte eine von denen:
"Stell dir mal vor,
ich bringe sowas heim."
"Mein Vater
würde mich gleich enterben."
Das war für mich sehr verletzend.
Am liebsten hätte ich ihr
eine scharfe Antwort gegeben.
Aber ich glaube, in so einer
Situation erreicht man nichts
mit einer scharfen Antwort.
Ich weiss ja eigentlich auch,
dass die Leute so denken.
Mich haben auch viele gefragt:
"Wie hat dein Vater reagiert?"
"Hat der das akzeptiert?"
Wir sind die Eltern von Salomé.
Von Salomé Kora.
Ah! Okay!
Kennst du sie?
- Ja, Kora.
* Applaus *
... die Schweizerin, Salomé Kora!
* Schuss *
Salomé! Hopp!
Komm, Salomé!
- Hopp, hopp, hopp!
11,42?
- Ja.
Es ist kalt. Und Gegenwind.
Scheisse, hm?
Das gibt's halt.
- Ja, so ist das.
Ich fliege ja Gleitschirm.
Ich ging Gleitschirmfliegen.
Ich sass in einem Achtergondeli.
es waren nur Männer.
Es herrschte die totale Stille,
niemand redete.
Und irgendwann
sagte einer dieser Männer:
"Von wo bist du?"
Oder: "Von wo kommst du?".
Ich merkte plötzlich,
okay, er redet mit mir.
Und antwortete aus der Region Biel.
Und er sagte:
"Nein. Von wo kommst du?"
Ich sagte dann, ich wisse nicht,
warum er mich das fragt.
Erstens kenne er mich nicht
und zweitens habe er sieben andere
Möglichkeiten, jemanden zu fragen,
woher dass er sei und warum er
jetzt ausgerechnet mich frage?
Das ist einfach eine Frage, die
eigentlich ständig davon ausgeht,
dass ich nicht von hier bin
oder nicht integriert bin
und kein Teil dieser Gesellschaft
bin.
Kay Kysela und Joel Gerber
sind seit der gemeinsamen Jugendzeit
in Aarberg/BE eng befreundet.
Ich kann mich
an eine Velokontrolle erinnern,
als wir von einem Klub
nach Hause gefahren sind.
Die Polizei hielt uns an und sagte,
ich solle vom Velo absteigen,
ich hätte das Velo geklaut.
Ich sagte:
"Nein, das ist mein Velo."
Dann sollte ich das beweisen.
Das war so eine Situation -
ich stand dumm da,
wie soll ich das beweisen?
Wer hat seine Velo-Quittung dabei,
kann sagen:
"Das ist mein Velo!
Hier die Quittungen!"
Eine andere Situation,
die wir mal mit der Polizei hatten,
als wir zusammen
mit dem Töff unterwegs waren Ð
nach dem Ausgang,
wir waren etwa 16 Ð
Kay hatte ein Töffli, ein cooles ...
Ð Ein pinkes!
... und ich sass hinten drauf.
Wir sahen in der Parallelstrasse
die Polizei, die uns gesehen hatte Ð
und es war unser Dorf, unsere Hood.
Wir wussten, wie abhauen.
Wir kamen bei mir zu Hause an.
Er schlief bei mir.
Wir freuten uns,
dass wir sie abgehängt haben.
Dann kamen sie von der Hauptstrasse
um die Ecke und fuhren zu uns.
Sie sahen uns, stiegen aus
und hielten nur Kay fest.
Sie drückten ihn an die Wand.
Der Verdacht war nur bei Kay.
Er wurde als Krimineller behandelt
und ich stand nebendran.
Dabei hatte ich
genau dasselbe gemacht.
Ich habe völlig ausgerufen.
- Ja.
Ich konnte es nicht glauben, ich
rief: "Das ist eine Frechheit!"
Schlussendlich sagten sie dir noch,
du sollest gehen.
Du sollest gehen, sonst
würdest du dir eine Busse holen.
Und du tobtest wie verrückt
und botst sogar noch deine Hände an.
Du sagtest,
sie sollten dich auch nehmen
und sie blieben einfach bei mir.
Das war intuitiv -
als Freund bin ich dortgeblieben.
Ich glaube, es half, ihnen immer
wieder den Spiegel vorzuhalten,
dass das, was sie gerade tun,
eine Frechheit ist.
In solchen Situationen merkte ich,
dass es nicht nur
mühsam und anstrengend,
sondern zutiefst ungerecht ist
und recht gefährlich werden kann.
Denn es war nicht verhältnismässig.
* Bedrückende Musik *
Willst du einen oder nicht?
Ich möchte schon einen,
damit ich ... Danke.
Salomé Kora und ihre Schwestern
verbrachten
einen Teil ihrer Kindheit in Benin.
2006 kam die Familie in die Schweiz.
... ein bisschen reintun.
- Ich nehme ihn mit nach draussen.
Wer braucht alles ein Glas?
Du Papa, hast uns als Kindern
das Denken mitgegeben,
dass wir uns beweisen müssen
und dass wir nicht negativ
auffallen sollten.
Denn uns behält man in Erinnerung.
Ich habe das starke Gefühl,
ich müsse es allen recht machen.
Das war mein Weg. Also, du auch.
Das hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt.
Es geht darum, ja niemandem
auf die Füssen zu treten.
Wisst ihr noch, als mir eine Weile
alle oder viele meiner Klasse
"Neger" nachriefen?
Das hat mich sehr verletzt.
- Das wusste ich nicht.
Das hat mich geprägt.
In welcher Klasse?
In der vierten Klasse.
Das fand ich megakrass.
Ich wusste nicht recht,
wie ich mich wehren soll.
Es kam für mich aus dem Nichts.
Woher kannten sie
dieses Wort überhaupt?
Es hat etwas mit meiner Hautfarbe
zu tun, es ist etwas Negatives.
Wieso beleidigen sie mich
wegen meiner Hautfarbe?
Ich verstand es nicht.
Dort, wo sie das Wort herhaben -
von einem Elternteil -,
dort war es ja
in einem negativen Zusammenhang.
Hattest du denn das Gefühl,
wir verstehen das nicht
und helfen dir nicht?
Es kann gut sein, dass ich euch
zu diesem Zeitpunkt schützen wollte.
Du hast uns ja auch Sachen
nicht erzählt, um uns zu schützen.
Das ist einfach so:
Man erträgt es lieber selbst,
als eine andere Person auch noch
damit zu belasten oder zu verletzen.
Alle haben Strategien entwickelt,
wie sie potenziell
rassistischen Situationen ausweichen.
Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen,
wir alle haben uns angewöhnt -
du vielleicht weniger,
dich stören Sachen z.T. weniger -
dass wir nicht
an gewisse Events gehen,
weil wir wissen,
dass wir dort nur verletzt werden.
Es tut uns nicht gut, hinzugehen.
Welche Events z.B.?
- OLMA, Fasnacht etc.
Das sind Orte, an denen
ich mich nicht sehr wohl fühle.
Wieso? Ich frage nur,
weil es mich interessiert.
An der OLMA bekam ich schon Bier
auf den Kopf und alles Mögliche.
Du hast das Gefühl, das war
wegen deiner Farbe?- Absolut.
Ich habe
auch schon solche Dinge erlebt.
Das nimmt mir die Lust,
in ein Restaurant zu gehen.
Wenn ich allein bin,
dann gehe ich gar nicht.
Ich habe mich
gar nicht daran gewöhnt,
allein etwas trinken zu gehen.
Denn solche Sachen
will ich nicht jedes Mal erleben.
Wenn du merkst, du bist dort,
keiner kommt zu dir,
andere sind gekommen
und werden dann schnell bedient
und irgendwann
trudelt jemand bei dir ein Ð
das ist einfach verletzend.
Letzthin wollte jemand anfangen,
rassistisch zu reden.
Dann habe ich prophylaktisch gesagt:
"Soll ich Ihnen mal sagen,
was ich für einen Mann habe?"
Es war ein 60-jähriger Mann.
Und er: "Aha."
"Mein Mann ist aus Afrika,
aus Benin."
Ich zeigte ihm mein Handy:
"Schauen Sie, meine Familie."
Dann sagt er:
"Ich bin doch kein Rassist!"
Ich wollte mich selbst schützen,
bevor er blöde Witze erzählt.
Ich merkte einfach,
es geht in eine Richtung,
als er anfing,
über die Ausländer zu schimpfen.
So nahm ich ihm den Wind aus den
Segeln, er konnte nichts mehr sagen.
Dann sagte er: "Ich bin doch
kein Rassist, aber wissen Sie,
die jungen Afrikanerinnen,
die schaue ich schon gerne an!"
* Lachen *
Er merkte wohl selbst ...
Das macht es nicht besser.
- Nein, er merkte es selbst.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Gut.
Guten Morgen zusammen.
- (Alle) Guten Morgen.
Ihr seid die ganze Woche in den
Altersheimen Sandbühl und Weiermatt.
Ihr seid unter der Leitung
von Kalvin Louis eingeteilt.
Ihr werdet direkt morgens einrücken
und abends auch wieder gehen.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier,
fünf, sechs, sieben ...
Ich dachte einfach,
es ist nicht sehr lange her,
als Männer in der Schweiz, wenn sie
eine Kaderposition haben wollten,
beweisen mussten, dass sie
Militärdienst geleistet haben
oder immer noch leisten.
Okay, Livio,
du kannst auch dort rüber.
Dann dachte ich, das könnte auch
für Leute mit Migrationshintergrund,
die beim Zivilschutz in der
Care-Arbeit arbeiten, etwas sein:
Wenn auch sie
Zivilschutzdienst leisten,
dann würden sie vielleicht für diese
Stellen eine bessere Chance haben.
Guten Tag, Frau Marti!
- Wir kennen uns schon!
Natürlich kennen wir uns.
Wie geht es?
- Danke, so weit gut.
So weit gut?
- Man hat schon seine Wehwehchen.
Yvonne kam mit der Idee auf mich zu,
Sie hat sich selbst darum bemüht.
Ich wäre nicht
auf die Idee gekommen,
insbesondere Migranten anzusprechen.
Das ist eine super Idee: Wir
haben zu wenig Leute im Zivilschutz,
wir haben keine Frauen,
das ist sowieso ein grosser Mangel.
Wenn dann noch jemand freiwillig
will - sofort, natürlich.
Wasser zu hören, es beruhigt mich.
- Ja, ja.
Es hat da zwei Goldfische.
- Wirklich?
Der Orange
lässt sich nicht immer blicken.
Okay.
- Sie sagt Rose. Rose spielen.
Entscheide, was ihr spielt.
Du kamst 2000 und 2009 nach Zürich?
- Mhm.
Dann bist du schon lange hier.
Mittlerweile habe ich
durch den Zivilschutz
sehr viele gute Leute kennengelernt.
Man bildet ein Netzwerk.
Ich treffe Leute, die ich sonst nir-
gends in meinem Leben treffen würde,
weil sie gegenüber dem,
was ich normalerweise tue,
so unterschiedliche Sachen machen.
Ich bin aus Liebe
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Wir waren neun glückliche Jahre
zusammen.
Der Trennungsgrund
klingt jetzt wirklich wie ein Witz.
Damals verstand ich es nicht,
als er sagte,
ich sei zu schweizerisch geworden.
Nach drei Jahren Ehe, dachte ich:
"Ich habe keine Freund/-innen hier,
ich fühle mich so einsam."
Ich komme aus einer Kultur,
wo wir kommunaler sind.
Jeder weiss, was der andere macht.
Wir sprechen mit jedem.
Hier kannte ich nach drei Jahren
die Nachbar/-innen nicht,
sie haben mich kaum gegrüsst.
Wenn wir sprachen, war das
über die Waschküche und ich dachte:
"Irgendwie muss ich das ändern,
sonst überlebe ich das nicht."
Ich fragte mich, was ich
machen kann. Ich singe gerne.
Ich googelte auf dem Computer
"traditionelle Schweizer Musik".
Die ersten paar Adressen, die
angezeigt wurden, schrieb ich an.
Es ging ums Jodeln Ð es gab einen
Herrn Josef Rempfler in Appenzell.
Ich schrieb:
"Herr Rempfler, ich bin Kenianerin,
ich möchte Jodeln lernen,
es könnte vielleicht meine Ehe und
mein Leben in der Schweiz retten."
* Blasorchestermusik im Hintergrund *
Bitte, gern geschehen.
Rede mit ihr ... Nein, nein, danke!
Danke, gleichfalls.
Es bedeutet mir sehr viel,
dass jemand wie ich
heute am 1. August auf dem Rütli
überhaupt auftreten darf.
* Sie macht Aufwärmübungen
für die Stimmbänder. *
* Alphornmusik *
* Sie jodelt. *
Es ist eine Chance für mich,
zu zeigen:
Wir sind ein Teil der Gesellschaft
hier in der Schweiz.
Wir wollen mitmachen, mitgestalten.
Ich vertrete jetzt
25 % der Leute hier in der Schweiz,
die einen Migrationshintergrund
haben, die nicht unbedingt überall,
z.B. an solchen Orten,
die Möglichkeit haben,
ihre Stimme zu erheben
und vertreten zu sein.
Für mich ist es wirklich eine Ehre.
* Sie jodelt
untermalt von Alphornmusik. *
* Die Musik
geht in eine Dissonanz über. *
* Antizipative Klänge *
Es hinterliess ein Schweregefühl.
So ein Unverständnis,
dass man mir nicht zuhört,
dass ich Dinge nicht sagen kann.
Ende September 2021
schwingt sich Kay Kysela
nach einer Theaterprobe aufs Velo.
Er will über Mittag
ins Hallenbad schwimmen gehen.
In einer Hand hält er sein Mobil-
telefon, um nach dem Weg zu schauen.
Plötzlich merkte ich, dass
hinter mir ein Velopolizist fährt.
Ich schaute nach hinten
und er fuhr an mir vorbei.
Auf meiner Höhe bremste er ab,
schaute mich ganz lange an
und musterte mich.
Ich dachte: "Okay ..." Aber
er sagte nichts und fuhr weiter.
Vor dem Bundesasylzentrum
wartet der Polizist.
Er signalisierte mir, dass ich an-
halten soll, was ich dann auch tat.
Er sagte: "Grüezi."
Ich sagte: "Hoi."
Dann fühlte er sich
ziemlich angegriffen,
dünkte es mich: Er sagte,
dass wir nicht per du seien,
und sagte: "Hier sagt man Grüezi."
Er sprach mit gebrochenem Deutsch.
Ich sagte, er könne
Schweizerdeutsch mit mir reden.
Ich hätte ihn nicht duzen wollen,
das tue mir leid, ich sage
einfach allgemein oft "hoi".
Er sprach dann weiter,
wieder in gebrochenem Deutsch,
und sagte, wir seien nicht Freunde,
wir seien nicht zusammen
zur Schule gegangen.
Er versuchte, mir andere Verhaltens-
weisen der Schweiz zu erklären.
Ich sagte wieder:
"Ich spreche Schweizerdeutsch."
Er solle mir doch bitte sagen,
worum es gehe,
warum er mich angehalten habe.
Aber er wollte die Diskussion
mit dem Duzen weiterführen.
Ich intervenierte wieder
und wollte wissen,
worum es gehe,
sonst würde ich gehen.
Die Situation wird aggressiver.
Weil er mit dem Polizisten allein
ist, fühlt sich Kay Kysela unwohl.
Er sagt, dass er
zur nahegelegenen Kunstschule gehe,
wo der Polizist die Kontrolle
mit Zeugen fortführen könne.
Ist es nicht ein bisschen dreist,
aus einer Polizeikontrolle
quasi einfach wegzugehen?
Ja, doch, natürlich. Es ist dreist.
Aber in dem Moment
war es für mich nicht dreist,
weil ich es angekündigt hatte.
Für mich war es so, dass ich
keine andere Möglichkeit hatte.
Ich kam mir so übergangen vor.
Ich war so ... Ich hatte keine ...
Ich konnte mich
in dem Moment nicht wehren.
Und das ist wie ...
Ich wurde auch laut und hitzig.
Ich merkte einfach:
Die Situation wird nicht besser.
Er alleine und ich alleine.
Und das ist wie ... Ja.
Kay Kysela fährt zur Kunstschule.
Der Polizist folgt ihm,
Verstärkung rast mit Sirene heran.
Kay Kysela hat Angst.
Nach einer längeren Diskussion
erhält er fürs Freihändig-Fahren
eine Busse von 20 Fr.
Er akzeptiert die Busse.
Ich war total aufgelöst,
danach brach ich bin in Tränen aus.
Ich wusste nicht mehr,
wie, was, wo, wann.
Ich bin total ... Ja.
Die Geschichte
ist mit der Busse noch nicht zu Ende.
Deshalb holt sich Kay Kysela
rechtlichen Beistand.
Doch eins nach dem andern.
Der Polizist will sich nicht äussern.
An seiner Stelle nimmt die
Medienchefin der Zürcher Stadtpolizei
zum Vorhalt Stellung,
dass Kay Kysela aufgrund seiner
Hautfarbe angehalten worden sei.
Diesen Vorwurf
weisen wir in aller Form zurück.
Ich habe mit dem Polizisten
gesprochen,
habe ihm von diesem Vorwurf,
der da im Raum steht, erzählt.
Er schaute mich ungläubig an,
da er den Mann nur anhalten wollte,
weil er Verkehrsübertretungen
begangen hat.
Es ging zu keinem Zeitpunkt um
das Aussehen oder um die Hautfarbe.
Myriam Dannacher
ist Kay Kyselas Anwältin.
Ich finde es durchaus plausibel,
dass das von der Stadtpolizei auch
eine Schutzbehauptung sein könnte,
die sich in dem Fall
hinter ihren Mitarbeiter stellt.
Natürlich müsste es
bei einer Bejahung der Frage,
ob es mit seiner Hautfarbe zu tun
hat, natürlich Konsequenzen haben.
Es ist einfacher
für die Stadtpolizei, zu sagen,
der ganze Fall habe nichts
mit Kays Hautfarbe zu tun.
Kay Kysela fährt zurück zum Theater.
Zufällig beobachtet er, wie der glei-
che Polizist, der ihn zuvor büsste,
jetzt eine junge weisse Frau anhält,
die freihändig Velo fährt.
Nach einem kurzen Gespräch
lässt der Polizist -
laut Kay Kysela - die Frau ziehen.
Ich war total sprachlos, ich dachte
wirklich: "Das gibt's nicht."
Und weil mein Gerechtigkeitssinn
irgendwie griff
und ich einen Ehrlichkeitsanspruch
hatte, sagte ich:
"Ich möchte gerne
noch mal mit Ihnen sprechen."
Er kam und ich dachte, wir könnten
das Gespräch noch mal führen.
Ich sagte,
was ich gerade gesehen hatte,
wovon ich gerade Zeuge geworden sei.
Ich sagte, genau davon
hätte ich ja gesprochen,
das sei eine ungleiche Behandlung
gewesen, das sei doch nicht okay.
Dann grinste er und sagte:
"Ja, aber sie war nett."
Das fand ich
eine total unprofessionelle
und respektlose Art mir gegenüber.
Ich war total ausser mir.
Ich sagte, das gehe nicht,
das sei nicht richtig und so.
Dann kippte die Situation,
er kam auf mich zu
und beschimpfte mich.
Es sagte, jetzt bekäme ich
eine richterliche Anzeige
und dagegen könne ich nichts machen.
Jetzt sei ich am Arsch.
Tatsächlich: Zwei Tage später trifft
eine Vorladung zur Einvernahme ein
wegen Hinderung einer Amtshandlung.
Für Kay Kysela ist klar: Das ist die
Quittung dafür, dass er sich wehrte.
Ist das üblich, dass man einen Straf-
befehl erst nachträglich ausspricht?
Der Polizist wollte den Mann
ja anhalten und kontrollieren.
Der Mann wollte sich
aber nicht kontrollieren lassen,
hat sich sogar
vom Kontrollplatz entfernt.
Das war dann auch der Grund,
weshalb es
nicht nur eine Ordnungsbusse gab,
sondern auch noch eine Rapportierung
wegen Hinderung einer Amtshandlung.
Das kann man als Polizei
nicht vor Ort machen.
Das gibt einen Bericht, einen
Rapport an die Staatsanwaltschaft,
die das dann beurteilt.
Kay Kysela wird verurteilt
zu einer bedingten Geldstrafe von
1'200 Fr. und einer Busse von 300 Fr.
Er wollte sich vor Gericht wehren.
Seine Anwältin
riet Kay Kysela davon ab:
Er hätte kaum eine Chance,
weil Gerichte in der Regel Polizisten
mehr Glauben schenken würden.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Ich finde es schwierig, weil wir in
uns drinnen so konditioniert sind,
dass wir immer Fehler
bei uns selbst suchen.
Und trotzdem finde ich,
es war richtig,
dass ich den Mund aufgemacht
und es versucht habe.
Ich frage mich einfach,
wie es jemandem geht,
der diese Möglichkeiten nicht hat.
Der sich nicht so
mit der Sprache wehren kann,
der nicht
den Schweizer Pass hervor holen,
sich nicht Gehör verschaffen kann,
weil es einfach nicht geht.
Kay Kysela muss nicht nur
Busse und Strafe zahlen:
Er hat auch
einen Eintrag im Strafregister.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Evelyn Wilhelm.
Mehr als anderthalb Jahre
sind seit dem Tod
ihres Bruders Roger Nzoy Wilhelm
in Morges am Bahnhof vergangen.
Von Anfang an fühlte sie sich im
Untersuchungsverfahren diskriminiert:
Ihr Anwalt musste etwa dafür kämpfen,
dass sie und ihr Bruder als Privat-
kläger überhaupt zugelassen wurden.
The appeal seems to be good.
Usually,
when the appeal is not good ...
Ich habe von nicht-farbigen
Mitmenschen noch nie gehört,
dass sie beweisen müssen,
dass sie ein enges Verhältnis
zu ihren Geschwistern haben.
Als die Staatsanwaltschaft
ihre Entscheidung traf,
ihnen die Teilnahme am Verfahren
als Nebenkläger zu verweigern,
bin ich beinahe vom Stuhl gefallen.
Das verstösst gegen das Gesetz.
Wir mussten
einen Rechtsbehelf einlegen.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft
musste zugeben,
dass sie einen Fehler gemacht hatte.
Vieles im Verfahren zum Tod
von Roger Wilhelm sei ungewöhnlich,
sagt Ludovic Tirelli.
Etwa, dass die Polizisten
bei der zweiten Einvernahme
andere Aussagen gemacht hätten
als bei der ersten.
Zudem hatten sie
gegenseitig Zugang zu ihren Aussagen.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft
sah darin kein Problem.
Aber noch mehr sei stossend.
Mich beunruhigt,
dass alle Polizisten sagten,
sie hätten nicht bemerkt,
dass er schwarz war.
Alle.
Dabei ist es doch offensichtlich.
Und es ist auch offensichtlich,
dass, wenn die Zentrale
einen Polizisten anruft,
um einen eintreffenden Krankenwagen
zu leiten,
man dann Informationen
zum Gesundheitszustand haben möchte.
Die einzige am anderen Ende der
Leitung mitgeteilte Information ist:
Es ist ein Mann
mit schwarzer Hautfarbe.
Wie kann man wissen, wie man jeman-
den behandelt, nur weil man weiss,
dass sie eine schwarze Hautfarbe
hat? Das ist absurd.
Das ist der Beweis dafür,
dass seine Hautfarbe
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt
ein Parameter in diesem Fall war.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft
will sich wegen des
laufenden Verfahrens nicht äussern.
Ich fühle mich total ungerecht
behandelt, von Tag 1 an.
Der Staatsanwalt
ist klar auf der Seite der Polizei,
das zeigt er immer wieder.
Da die beiden
auch so eng zusammenarbeiten Ð
Polizei und Staatsanwalt Ð glaube
ich nicht an ein faires Verfahren.
Aber ich bin total froh,
habe ich einen Anwalt,
der uns da hindurch hilft.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Jean Ziegler sagte:
"Alles, was das
Böse braucht, um zu triumphieren,
ist das Schweigen
der guten Menschen."
Ich kämpfe dagegen an. Ich will
mich nicht immer nur anpassen.
Oft, wenn ich mit Kolleginnen und
Kollegen über Rassismus reden will,
kommt:
"Aber ich bin nicht rassistisch."
"Das ist doch schon mal ein Start."
Bravo! Schön! Sehr cool.
Trotzdem passieren mir
häufig wieder Sachen,
bei denen ich mich
angegriffen fühle.
Ich finde es auch eine gewagte Aus-
sage: "Ich bin nicht rassistisch."
Das würde auch ich nicht von mir
sagen.- Nein, wirklich nicht.
Wenn mir jemand sagt:
"Ich bin kein Rassist",
dann weiss ich:
"Du bist ganz sicher einer."
Du hast die Problematik
nicht begriffen,
wenn du das von dir behauptest.
Jeder Mensch
ist auf irgendeine Art rassistisch.
Wichtig ist, sich Gedanken zu machen
und zu versuchen, besser zu werden.
* Die Demonstrant/-innen
skandieren. *
(Frau ruft) Alle zusammen!
- (Alle) Gegen den Rassismus!
Es sind sehr viele Leute.
Es ist überwältigend.
Es ist die Arbeit von vielen Organi-
sationen, die sich ausgezahlt hat.
Jetzt kann man den Fall
nicht mehr unter den Teppich kehren.
Die Untersuchung
ist nicht abgeschlossen.
Wann der Fall vor Gericht kommt,
weiss Evelyn Wilhelm nicht.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Lisa Pfeiffer, Kira Euler - 2023